Tag 4 nach dem Bruch des Staudamms von
kachowka im Süden der Ukraine das Wasser
das in den Fluss die Pro gelaufen ist
steigt jetzt nicht mehr es ist
internationale Hilfe da für die Ukraine
und heute wurde bekannt dass auch die
russische besetzten Teile dass da auch
die Rettungsarbeiten angelaufen sind die
Schäden sind riesig für Menschen Tiere
und die Umwelt und noch gar nicht
abschätzbar und dieser Stausee der war
nicht nur für die Bewässerung der Felder
und der kompletten Landwirtschaft
vorgesehen sondern eben auch für die
Kühlung eines nahegelegenen
Atomkraftwerks des größten in Europa das
kann Kraftwerk saporicia was also dieser
Daumenbruch für dieses Kernkraftwerk
bedeutet darüber kann ich jetzt sprechen
mit Uwe Stoll er ist der technisch
wissenschaftliche Geschäftsführer der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für Anlagen und
Reaktorsicherheit grüße Sie Herr Stoll
Enz der Chef der internationalen
atomenergieagentur grossi hat von einer
gefährlichen Sicherheitslage gesprochen
trotz
dessen dass es genug Kühlwasser wohl
noch gibt was bedeutet das und wie sind
diese Anlagen verbunden
das sind jetzt verschiedene Ebenen über
diese Reden zuerst vorneweg zur Kühlung
die Kühlung des Kraftwerks erfolgt über
einen riesigen kühlteich der ein sehr
kleine Verbindung zum Stausee hat diese
Verbindung ist geschlossen das heißt im
Moment ist der kühlteich voll gefüllt
mit einem Pegelstand von 16,66 Metern
während der Stausee langsam leer läuft
und so sein Minimum Pegel bei ca 10
Meter erreichen wird das heißt die
Kühlung der AKW ist aktuell überhaupt
nicht in Frage gestellt es wäre dann aus
zu diskutieren wenn es zu Beschädigungen
an diesen Teich oder diesen Kanal kommt
der aktuell das den kühlteich des
Kraftwerks vom Stausee drin
wie ist denn die Kühlung dauerhaft
gesichert denn der Reaktor also die
sechs Reaktoren sind ja abgeschaltet
aber sie brauchen ja trotzdem noch
Kühlung
ja die Kühlung der abgebrannten
Brennelemente man nennt das nachts auf
als Leistung die muss natürlich überall
einen langen Zeitraum gewährleistet sein
und die erfolgt jetzt noch durch ein
komplett anderes System sogenannte
sprinklerteiche dessen geschlossenes
System über die die Wärme abgeführt wird
und dort muss ich dann Wasser ergänzen
also Wasser was verdunstet muss ergänzt
werden das sind wenige Kubikmeter am Tag
die werden normalerweise aus dem
kühlteich entnommen können aber auch auf
anderen Wegen zum Beispiel aus Brunnen
die auf dem Anlagengelände sind gewonnen
werden
das Atomkraftwerk ist ja nicht mehr am
Netz braucht aber Strom zur Kühlung auch
von außen gilt das auch für die Kühlung
an sich
für die Kühlung brauche ich immer Pumpen
und diese Punkten brauchen natürlich
Strom damit sie laufen können
gut an die nächste Frage was passiert
wenn das AKW von der Stromversorgung
abgeschnitten sein sollte
in dem Fall sind im Kraftwerk natürlich
nur schon diese vorhanden das heißt die
sicherheitstechnisch wichtigen
Verbraucher also die ich brauche um die
abgebrannten Brennelemente zu kühlen die
sind alle mit diesen Notstrom diesen
versorgbar davon hat jeder Block drei
man braucht aktuell nur einen und die
würden in dem Fall einspringen im Moment
wie gesagt hat man das in diesem Fall
schon siebenmal seit Beginn des Krieges
das hat immer funktioniert allerdings
gibt es dann immer auch die Frage es
muss natürlich auch die Versorgung mit
wie sie sichergestellt sein
und auch Schmieröl oder andere
Verbrauchsmaterialien die die diese
brauchen
welche verschiedenen Optionen hat das
Kraftwerk um eventuelle Ausfälle des
einen oder anderen Kühlsystems
aufzufangen
dabei der geringen Menge die man aktuell
dort an Wasser braucht habe ich
natürlich wie schon erwähnt wenn ich den
Kühlturm nicht mehr zur Verfügung habe
habe ich Brunnen ich kann mir aber auch
vorstellen dass man diese Mengen mit
trangglaszügen anfahren kann es gibt
aber auch Notfallpläne in dem Kraftwerk
dass man nahegelegene auch vom Stausee
unabhängige Fischteiche oder ein tiefes
Hafenbecken was dann in der Nähe ist als
wasserreservant nutzen kann
jetzt liegt ja dieses Kraftwerk direkt
an der Frontlinie und könnte auch selbst
wieder Ziel von Angriffen werden was
sind denn die größten Risiken der Zeit
die größten Risiken sehe ich nach wie
vor im Personal das Personal ist ja
deutlich ausgedünnt früher waren mal vor
Beginn des Krieges 11.000 Menschen im
Kraftwerk beschäftigt aktuell sind noch
3.500 und der psychologische Lage ist
das was sie zu meinem allermeisten
Sorgen macht jeder von diesen
Mitarbeitern hat Familie die Leben
vielleicht in den Gebieten die jetzt
überhaupt sind wo man sich Sorgen macht
und trotzdem soll man seine wichtige
sicherheitstechnisch wichtige Arbeit
machen also das sind die größten Sorgen
die wir momentan
jetzt will der iaa-chef grossi dorthin
reisen was verspricht sich die
internationale Gemeinschaft von einem
weiteren Besuch
also der hat von Anfang an das Krieges
versucht doch eine sag mal
demilitarisierte Zone zu schaffen wo
keine Kriegshandlungen stattfinden und
die Sorge die man im Moment hat ist dass
es genau in dem Gebiet jetzt zu dieser
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine kommt und das
glaube ich keiner beabsichtigtes
Kraftwerk anzugreifen aber das ist dann
doch eventuell zu Kollateralschäden
kommt deshalb ja auch der Wunsch von
grossi um das Kraftwerk rum eine
demilitarisierte so Zone zu schaffen
dass es auch nicht aus Versehen zu
Beschädigung oder Angriff auf das
Kraftwerk kommen kann
für Sie wahrscheinlich halten sie das
dass eine
entmilitarisierte Sonne eingesetzt wird
nicht auch der versucht deshalb aber
März letzten Jahres die beiden
Kriegsparteien dazu zu bewegen dort habe
ich immer wieder das Problem dass die
eine oder die andere Seite Gründe hat
warum man da nicht mitmacht die hierher
hat aber auch seit ja seit ein
dreiviertel Jahr dort ständige
Beobachter die alle vier bis sechs
Wochen ausgetauscht werden und dabei
immer die Frontlinie geübt werden müssen
also die Situation ist nach wie vor da
instabil die Russen haben angeblich zu
Verteidigung des Kraftwerks dort auch
Militär stationiert auch wie Waffen
gelagert also die Situation ist sehr
unübersichtlich und er spricht in weiten
Teilen dem was man international sich
vereinbart hat zur Sicherheit von
Kranken
was muss am dringendsten passieren um
Unfälle zu vermeiden
oh unsere zu vermeiden am besten dass
man den Krieg einstellen und keine
Kriegshandlungen um das Kraftwerk
rumführen
des zweiten natürlich sich sicherstellen
dass ich mir zuverlässige
Stromversorgung habe wir hatten ja
gesagt von den vielen Leitungen die das
normalerweise das Kraftwerk an Stromnetz
anbinden ist noch eine verfügbar und die
fällt immer wieder aus durch
Kriegshandlung das sind so die
wichtigsten Dinge und es muss natürlich
ausreichen qualifiziertes Personal da
sein um dieses Kraftwerk auch sicher
selbst im abgeschalteten Zustand zu
betreiben
es gibt ja die eine oder andere Aussage
dass die Kühlung für die verbliebenen
Rektoren nicht mehr ausreicht wie ordnen
Sie das ein wo kommen diese Bedenken her
also für die bestehenden Reaktionen
würde sie nicht ausreichen um die Anlage
ich sag mal als Kernkraftwerk zu
betreiben und damit Strom zu produzieren
wenn die sechs Blöcke laufen brauchen
sich eine kühlmenge von 12.000 Megawatt
also ja wie soll ich das jetzt
übersetzen das ist
ja wir haben einen Spitzenbedarf in
Deutschland von 80.000 Megawatt das
heißt ich habe da eine ganz erhebliche
Menge an
Kühlmittel was ich brauche und von dem
Anteil verdunstet und das muss
normalerweise aus dem Stausee ersetzt
werden da der stause jetzt nicht nur
verfügbar ist ist damit eigentlich
ausgeschlossen dass die Blöcke wieder
zur Stromerzeugung ins Netz gehen
letzte Frage inwiefern besteht überhaupt
aus ihrer Sicht akute Gefahr für das
Atomkraftwerk reparieren
sehe ich nicht für das Kraftwerk es
bietet aufgrund der Auslegung eines
Kernkraftwerks in gewissen Grundschutz
auch gegen sag mal zufälligen Beschuss
allerdings ist die Sorge immer vorneweg
Personal und auch die sichere
Stromversorgung
der Ukraine ist es bisher gelungen die
zerstörte Leitung immer halt ich sag mal
maximal eines Tages wieder aufzubauen
aber als ich um diese Leitungen ergeben
und eine längerfristiger Ausfall der
Stromversorgung kommt
da muss man wirklich schauen wie lange
erreichen die diese verräte und bin ich
in der Lage wenn die Front dort verläuft
überhaupt zusätzlich in diesem Jahr
Anlage zu bringen
soweit der technisch wissenschaftliche
Geschäftsführer der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für Reaktorsicherheit Uwe
Stoll vielen Dank für das Interview
danke schön